nobody knows this is what we do know
this is what psychologists do no they do
know that we tend to fall in love with
somebody from the same socio-economic
background same ethnic background same
general level of intelligence same
general level of good looks same
religious and social values we tend to
be drawn to somebody who can give us the
lifestyle that we're looking for our
childhood certainly plays a role and
we're now beginning to find some
biological things that draw you to some
people rather than another new data
shows that women with a particular
immune system are drawn to men who have
an opposite immune system so there's a
lot of factors priming plays a role
proximity plays a role there's many
factors in who you love who you choose
but I began to even you can walk into a
room and everybody is from your
background same general level of
intelligence same general level of
clothes and you don't fall in love with
all of them so why is it that we're
almost chemically pulled to one person
rather than another so I wanted to see
if I could figure out the role of basic
body chemistry and so I looked through a
whole lot of biological data and there's
a lot of chemicals in the brain but most
of them keep the eyes blinking or help
with swallowing in order to keep the
heart beating etc not many of them are
linked with with personality traits for
chemicals actually six chemicals are
related to personality traits so I wrote
down on separate sheets of paper all
those traits associated with the
dopamine system the serotonin system the
testosterone system and the last being
the estrogen and the oxytocin system and
then I decided I would create a
questionnaire to see to what degree you
express these four basic biological
systems we all express all of them but
we express some more than others and
then I would watch on this dating site
chemistry dot-com and see not only what
your chemistry was but who you were
naturally drawn to and as it turns out
people were very expressive of the
dopamine system go for people like
themselves if you are high-energy very
curious have a lot of interest
of novelty willing to take risks to do
new things you want somebody like
yourself and I don't it's not just
jumping off mountains
I mean it's somebody will go to the
Opera with you the theater with you art
exhibits with you
etc so the Explorer or I call the
Explorer the high dopamine type tends to
go for people like themselves so does
the high serotonin type I call these
people the Builder Plato called them the
Guardian that's a better term these
people are cautious but not fearful
they're conventional traditional they
are calm social - very managerial
they're very good a very thorough
punctilious orderly conscientious loyal
they want somebody like themselves
serotonin goes for serotonin but the
last two types people are expressible
the testosterone system going for people
who are expressive of the estrogen
systems use me but the last two types
those two people who were those who were
expressive of the testosterone system
both men and women tend to be attracted
to those who are their opposites those
who are expressive of the estrogen
system I think a very good example is
Hillary and Bill Clinton she is I think
very expressive of the testosterone
system direct decisive tough-minded
certainly very ambitious self-contained
and what does she go she goes for Bill
very much of the high estrogen he's got
in that high testosterone toe but he's
certainly very high estrogen I mean he
cries when Hillary makes his speech he
feels everybody's pain he sees the big
picture the whole world knows it can't
stop talking linguistic skills or in the
estrogen system he's got wonderful
people's skills
I'm glad the government sent him into
North Korea to get those two girls out
rather than his wife but anyway the
highest region in the high testosterone
tend to be attracted to each other
and what I think they're doing from a
Darwinian perspective is pulling very
different resources I think the
tough-minded
high testosterone
I call the director needs the compassion
and the empathy and the people skills of
the highest region type and I think the
highest region type needs the
decisiveness the directness the
ambitiousness of the high testosterone
type so I think we evolved three really
very different ways of playing the
mating game I think that the high
testosterone and high estrogen are
pulling very different resources to
raise their babies that's they've got
very fine strength between the two of
them I think that the very traditional
type what I call the Builder is
capitalizing on very powerful strengths
for raising babies when they marry
another builder this other person is
going to respect the rules are going to
follow traditions there they they
they're gonna be loyal it's a very
strong combination for raising babies
but I wondered why is it the two of the
explorer' types the high dopamine types
what I mean if they're both great
adventurous who's gonna take care of the
baby while they just race off to climb
Mount Everest and what began to occur to
me maybe and I don't have the data on
this yet
maybe these people are more likely to
have a series of marriages what I call
serial monogamy and have children with
each different marriage in which case
they're creating more genetic variety in
their young so there are three different
ways of passing your DNA on to tomorrow